-My next guest is an activist
who's featured in the new
documentary "Us Kids,"
which is in theaters
and on demand this Friday.
Please welcome X Gonzalez!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ha ha! Yeah!
Oh, it's so good to see you.
You --
We've had Zoom guests before,
but I don't think anyone
has ever Zoomed
from their dorm room.
This is the first --
-I know.
it's pretty nice, isn't it?
Gives everybody
some nice memories.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I have my artwork.
I've got my tie dye.
-I want to ask you about "X."
-Yeah, so, I used to be --
My name is Emma Gonzalez,
but I've decided to go by X now
because I really don't want
people who don't know me
assuming that they do know me
because of
the national narrative
or international narrative
that exists about me.
Because I was
and still am a child,
and I don't want people thinking
that they're my friends
just 'cause they know my name,
and it also got kind of
tied up into my gender.
I realized that I'm not a girl
and that I don't like
when people refer to me
with she/her pronouns
or when they think of me
as a girl.
And Emma as a name
just became such an identity
that I became
really disassociated with.
And so I kind of took towards X
as a sort of, like,
I'm re-claiming
my own identity,
and if you see me,
don't assume that you know me.
Just assume that you're
seeing, like, a person.
-Yeah, very good.
Good for you.
Well, again, X, welcome.
You're actually majoring
in activism.
-Yes, yes.
-Which I can't think of a more
perfect thing to major in.
Is that what you saw yourself
majoring in or no?
-Yeah, when I was growing up,
I really wanted to work at NASA,
you know,
especially because I'm a Florida
native and NASA's here,
and I really wanted to, like,
work at the desks
and stuff
that you see in movies.
But I think now that's just
got to be one of those, like,
special-interest topics
that I'm just really into.
But, yeah,
I'm majoring in activism.
I have been taking
some of the coolest classes
with some of the coolest
professors at my college,
New College of Florida.
Come here if you're of college
age and want to go to college.
It's a really,
really cool school.
I've been taking some radical
learning sort of classes,
like manifestos, alternatives
to capitalism and socialism,
post-colonial literature
and theory,
Black social
and political thought,
global politics,
radical comics, like --
I can't even name them all.
They're so fascinating
and so, like --
I feel like sometimes my skull
is being, like, cracked open,
and information is being
directly beamed into my brain.
-I want to talk about, actually,
your documentary, "Us Kids."
-Yes!
-This is --
It follows you
and other activists
organizing March For Our Lives
after surviving
a school shooting in 2018.
The film premiered at Sundance,
and I think I read somewhere
it got one of the longest
standing ovations in history.
-Yeah,
in the history of Sundance.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can you talk a little bit
about some of the things
March For Our Lives has done?
-Yeah, I actually
kind of want to shout out
some of the members
of March For Our Lives
that are in the audience
right now.
Maxwell Frost, Elena, Brianni,
Gaby Salazar, Mia, Crystal,
Matthew Hogenmiller,
all my friends!
-Welcome!
-I love you.
-Love you back!
-Oh, they love you back!
This is happening. I love this.
-But, like, I was
one of the people who --
And you see it
in the documentary,
and I highly recommend
you watch it.
I was at, like, the merch table,
and we would be selling merch,
like, March For Our Lives merch,
and all the money would go
to the local areas that
we were in for those events.
And, like,
so, people would come up to me,
say hi to me, and would
take pictures and stuff,
and then they'd move on
to the next person
because it was such
a long line of people.
And we did that
like three events a day,
every day for 64 days,
and I only took
a half a day off.
-Wow. That's what
I'm talking about.
-Which is fun to say.
Cannot recommend
anybody else do that.
Don't look at this movie
and think,
"Hey, I should do that."
-How old were you when
that shooting took place?
-I was, like, 18?
I had just turned 18.
I had just gotten my license.
My driver's license.
-I've seen some interviews
around you
where people just go up to you
because you became
the face at one point,
the face of this whole
March For Our Lives.
And people were just yelling
at a 17-year-old kid,
and it just
must be tough for you.
I just go like --
Good for you for just being --
just logically going,
"Great. You can yell.
But let's talk to each other
and let's have a conversation."
-Yeah, thanks.
I agree, though,
it was kind of unbelievable
the amount of situations
that we were, like,
"Okay, I'm going to come to this
with a rational head
and be, like,
a violence interrupter.
I'm going to try.
I'm going to try and just
have a real conversation
with a real person."
And all these people
would come and protest
our events and stuff,
and they would be like,
"You don't know what
you're talking about!"
And I'm like, "Do you know
what you're talking about?
What is the media
saying about us?
What do you think
that we're trying to do?"
And they would say,
"We think that you're trying
to take our guns away,"
and I would be like,
"Okay, well, first of all,
that's not true.
We are not advocating
for taking guns away."
March For Our Lives
is an organization
that supports
the Second Amendment.
It's actually, in fact,
an organization
that supports the regulation
of the militia that,
you know, that is mentioned
in the Second Amendment.
So, in actuality, we should
all be working together.
We should not be fighting
with each other.
And when we had these
conversations on the ground
with these people,
everybody found out
how much we all had in common
with each other,
and, like, all the --
It was basically,
like, a cease-fire.
Nobody would argue anymore.
Nobody was screaming and stuff.
We would just, like, vibe
and just leave.
Everybody would, like --
-Yeah, such a proud moment,
I think, for this country to
see you and everyone doing that.
I want to show a clip.
Here is X Gonzalez in "Us Kids."
Take a look at this.
-You think you have enough in
the movement to keep it really?
-Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
I mean,
we have years and years more
than these people
are gonna live,
so we have a lot of time
on our hands.
♪♪
I'm in no way, like, hiding
under a rock or going dormant.
I'm not going to be quiet.
♪♪
I'm majoring in activism.
In school. That's my thing.
I'm just doing things
on my own terms.
-X Gonzalez.
"Us Kids" is in theaters
and on demand this Friday.
Thanks again for being here.
I appreciate it.